You said some beautiful stuff like all she's loyal or there's something else you
said and I want him to repeat it.
Oh my God.
When you're,
when you're,
when you're walking by me,
why you said that you know,
you,
you move side to side.
My name is Paula.
We've been together for three years.
My name is ty train.
I'll relationship.
It feels brand new.
Then we stay on.
That was good.
My first question is pretty easy.
Okay.
How did you two meet
my friend?
She said thank you.
Call a really good with my best friend ty.
I was Waco.
I don't date black guys.
She was like,
not like wrong boom,
like ty,
he's Asian.
I was like,
well,
I don't take agents either.
She was like,
well,
it's time for you to date outside your race because it's not working.
So we went out once a year for three years.
Yeah,
I think he calls it playing hard to get.
I did.
He was just so normal when I was like,
you're crazy.
And me.
The sweaty we would takes off in and every time my question comes up with,
so when we're going to hang out,
oh,
will not get a reply.
She would text me,
Louise say,
how you doing or how you been my we actually be well,
well well
and that question will come up again.
So what am I winning?
You let me take you out showing.
I'll reply.
So like every 30 days,
I guess one texts I center was,
you may be busy but if you really want to hang out with someone,
you will make the time to hang out with them.
You will find the time.
And she gave me the time.
He thinks how he just thinks that it's a cause.
I was like to get ah,
you know,
all the time I was playing hard to get.
Yeah.
I wasn't really playing hard to get,
I was just
playing,
you know all that.
They like Mexican stuff.
Yeah.
So I just thought you were going to be like,
damn,
that's crazy.
No,
he didn't know you were so Mexican savvy.
That's what it was.
I understand.
Wow.
How old are you?
how has the age difference?
Um,
he teaches me stuff,
how to handle situations because I'm not young anymore,
so I can't be like,
oh,
see,
I don't see it affecting.
I said,
Oh,
I think me and her were pretty much the same.
I think it's the same like that.
Alright,
you're mocking me.
It was tough at some point she didn't understand in the alarm.
I'm pretty understanding myself,
so she needs to go through it to understand to,
to grow up.
But I don't,
I don't look too old though.
Right.
I don't look too old.
Okay.
I said you were going to say like,
really?
I don't,
I don't see it.
I thought he was at all like,
yeah man,
we,
she mock me.
I do that quite often.
Work 10 12 years apart.
It was a learning curve for you and there's things I haven't been throwing you
haven't
this week.
We've just,
we've gone through some really big learning experiences,
so I don't know right now
she's very deep.
She can express her feelings very well.
While I can't express my feeling as well as she can.
Paula said you are working through some things in your relationship.
Oh,
oh,
ah.
What it all came down to is husband and wife.
We put each other first.
It's no matter what we put each other first we have to me,
I mean it feels like we have an obligation to our children to,
you know,
care for them and put of course their wellbeing first,
but after a certain age,
you know,
just it's your wife first and your husband first.
What is put your,
your wife first.
That's what you should do.
I think it's been a beautiful learning experience.
I mean it wasn't beautiful going through it because you know,
going through it is never a beautiful,
especially if we're going to get married.
Yeah.
Forever.
It makes you so attracted to her
by appearance.
I love the way she walks when she walks from behind it.
She,
she walks left right,
left,
right.
That's appearance.
But she's very loving man.
When this girl knows that you're on her side,
she will do anything and everything for you.
There's something I would like to say
that day when she becomes my wife.
We were good people before we met each other.
We'd gone to this relationship.
We made each other better.
She teaches me how to express my feelings when I've always had a hard time
learning and knowing how to do that.
I'll probably end up crying.
Recently my son,
our son,
he was,
um,
in the middle of a bra and his mom was the main attraction.
I didn't want to be in the middle of the drop of the Bra.
I didn't,
it was so fast and I just went down and I was just down.
I was covered and I was just,
I'm so worried because I'm thinking like,
oh my God,
who has my son Tom Ice?
I looked over my son,
you know,
ty had him and protected him and tie,
cried and tight doesn't.
And so,
um,
to see ty cry and to see my child be protected by this strong man,
it was like,
okay,
that's it.
Like I read my life,
like,
I'll sell my soul to you.
Like,
yeah,
my hero.
Since some beautiful stuff like
oil or something else.
You said.
Oh my God.
When you're,
when you're walk are you said that you know,
you move side to side,
maybe Jesus.
What did your mom,
nope,
that time learning how to tap.
Yeah.
The fact that by the time I was able to get up and think straight and ask
where's my son,
Ruben?
And the fact that before I was even finish that sentence,
when you had him under your care,
like Oh,
forever everything.
Yeah.
Even when you think I met my toughest,
always lucky no matter what.
Yeah.
Chicken,
Joe cry.
I think you can just say period.
That was a little bit like all like ha ha.
Yeah.
Thought it was going.
We had to.
We should.
God Man,
that's a good question.
That's all right.
My question.
Like what do you like most about my hair or eyelashes?
Oh Man.
Okay.
Yo got it.
Okay,
so this is my true belief,
fam.
Lemme Tell Ya,
you should subscribe in the day yet until you go to,
Oh,
you're supposed to wrap.
Please do not unsubscribe.
In fact,
this button,
if you want more and subscribe rap battles.
That's right.
We should put like a more videos right here though,
right here.
Okay.
Let's do it,
but they're all right.
Good.
Cool.
Okay.